he's Tom Curren NBC sports Boston where
are you right now Tom I'm over at the
gym Dan I go to the gym pretty much
every day around this time
so I appreciate not being on only in
line because for tickets very variable
I'm not on a on a landline so
apologizing in advance for any weirdness
that occurs are you working out with
Brady's trainer Alex Guerrero right now
at the moment no but I will be using and
incorporating some of his principles of
hydration and pliability could you do
them while you do the interview can you
do any of these is it Pilates pliability
wait what exactly do you do it honestly
honest to god and I swear to God I did
this stuff does help I have gone to see
him I paid my i paid my fare and I've
seen one number of times my kids have
seen them it's really it's something
called Active Release therapy if you
have an injury and if you don't it's
basically just you know don't put a lot
of weights on your joints use resistance
bands and that's the big change the
Gronk made in the offseason going from
weights to resistance bands and now he
has a lot more flexibility is bought in
diet wise and hydration wise and then
made a massive difference alarm and
that's really to cut to the chase
it's not Alex it's the ability to use
Alex and do your own thing that cause
kind of the flashpoint and that's why so
much this stuff is flowing from Tom's
wanting to be liberated in a sense and
not have to deal with resistance all
right what do you make of this tweet by
chef T that Brady still hasn't committed
to 2018 I didn't know that is there an
official date that he normally commits
to an upcoming season but this tweet
sort of making the rounds here what can
what do you make of it no that's fine
it's really he soft place the same stuff
that I've been reporting for more than a
month really good he hasn't committed
I've tried my best said this on a
podcast last week to ferret out a hard
and firm commitment that he's playing in
this year and I just have not been able
to do it you know no one has said yeah
Tom's definitely coming back it's
actually been avoided Gotham Chopra and
making the rounds said at one point the
next few weeks and months are critical
Brady himself said he had to read you
know recalibrate and and get that kind
of conviction back that he has has had
and he still hasn't done it and I think
some of it is linked to disgruntlement
it the way in the atmosphere and the way
things were done in 2017 and maybe just
over the course of time as well how long
does it go on I think that's really what
the question is and does he inevitably
retire okay Ben Bowlin headed to no no
it's okay
Ben Bowlin had a tweet that this morning
where he said he was hearing that maybe
Brady's doing this on purpose that
creating some drama for Belichick in the
offseason what do you make of that it is
that tongue-in-cheek or is that
something that Ben is being serious
about no I don't think that's fine she
can I absolutely think that that look I
think the Tom when Tom notes through
Gisele when Tom versus time that he
wants to feel appreciated and have fun
well if he doesn't feel appreciated for
taking less money over the years and
putting himself out there and always
taking the bullets for the franchise you
know when anytime there's a conflict
what better way to show that you feel
unappreciated then wait until your
safety net is removed from the picture
and then all of a sudden say you know
what I'm not actually sure I'm gonna
conclude play keep playing or not it's
all I think there isn't an aspect of it
yeah but but if he he's only gonna play
for the Patriots if this is all done
then he retires a patriot he you can't
see him in it's in another uniform I
absolutely positively could and he has
talked openly about that over the years
to Dan you know I want to finish my
career here this is where I want to be
this he might want to play for but not
everyone gets to dictate where they
finish and I absolutely could see him
playing someplace else I just get the
feeling that gizelle I know she said
it's a it's up to him but man that's a
strong influence that you have there and
and I honestly thought if they won the
Superbowl Tom that Brady was gonna
retire I really thought that
did you think that was a likelihood or a
possibility I thought it was a
likelihood but I see I had said this a
year ago where I thought if they won the
Super Bowl this is before they traded
Garoppolo for a bag of candy that
Garoppolo Barak you know the Garoppolo
was gonna take his place they were gonna
win the Superbowl Garoppolo was gonna
take over and he was gonna retire I
honestly thought that that was going to
happen not not just a you know whatever
possibility I really thought that and
here's the thing you know it's not just
to sell I remember in 2012 I actually
went to it bu one of those concussion
seminars was with Tom Brady's dad you
know we've talked in the past he and I
about it
and his concerns mr. Brady they said you
should come and see this with me so we
went over there so it's it's very much
in the forefront of his dad's mind and
his mom's mind then at 40 years old with
three kids who are you know not just
little balls of meat with eyes they're
working humans I think that he's getting
a different perspective on things and
his mother's mortality that he
experienced last year all those things
factored into it
then throw in you know the Malcolm
Butler situation if you will get Danny
Amendola as quotes earlier this week
talking about blood sweat and tears put
in almost insinuating that he felt
betrayed if he feels that way how much
Brady feel well also and I I do applaud
Belichick because he didn't spill any
gossip on Malcolm Butler hey I don't
know if that plays out in the locker
room at all that you know there's no
gossip about Malcolm Butler and why he
sat him down no I would be a hypocrite
that he sat him down in the Super Bowl
there but trying to figure out this
whole Tom doesn't feel appreciated and I
I don't know it just did it it's
interesting and it's if there's
something there I you know even though
they're close lip about it I think that
the really the genesis of it you
mentioned Jimmy I think the genesis
other probably was 2014 right around
this time of year with Belichick stood
up and said we all understand Tom's
contract status and his age and then
they went and drafted Garoppolo and then
behind the scenes Garoppolo was very
much well taken care of very much
treated as the heir yeah well Brady you
know went about his business leading the
team over and over again to a level of
success that they had experienced you
know a decade plus
or so I think that that's throughout
that landscape he's coming to work he's
working for a little bit less well every
day he has to look at his would-be
replacement being groomed to replace him
I think that that absolutely factors
into the quote unquote unappreciated
feel how high do they drop the
quarterback
part of me honestly part of me feels as
if Adams quote to the Adams tweet today
and story is part of an effort perhaps
on the teams part to smoke Brady out to
find out we had a definitive answer from
him
to help figure out for them when they
should draft a quarterback by trying to
get a commitment or non commitment out
of Brady so I think some of it actually
depends on what happens in the next
couple of days what about Gronk did you
see him today there's an Instagram
picture of him in a pool in Texas with
his girlfriend saying he's my he's my
water skis I mean this stuff just goes
sideways up their posterior they're
starting their OTAs the whole team has
been buying in for 18 years to this
Thomson clutter and Gronk's in a pool in
Texas I I said open revolt the other day
I don't even know if that was I don't
think that was overstating it what can
you max out on the bench I got long arms
but I have I have I don't max oh come on
this is a personal quit all you're
supposed to say that when you come on
your show aren't you yeah we're just
height and weight
no but it's heightened weight and if you
gotta a max I mean you're in a gym right
now like if you got on the bench press
fans I can use I can do the yellow bands
a bunch of times yeah I don't care about
that nobody cares about how many you
know I can absolutely outshoot you two
by the way what are you fine better
suitor than you are you hi I'm a better
shooter than you
every day at noon you come come right on
up to the rain and Athletic Club and get
you know if you want a piece of it then
you come down here Home Slice like I
don't know way games it's a home game
you come and kiss the ring here yes yes
unless you're afraid huh
oh you know what I'll do I'm gonna make
it quick when I beat you because I like
you that's great
I am gonna come in full rexspecs high
yeah man that means we're naked
if the Full Monty is you're gonna be
naked so I don't want that time oh I
didn't know what it meant
sorry don't pull the groin they're in
the gym always great to talk to you
thank you Tom okay buddy that's Tom
Curren for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]